hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back black forest castle we
are going back in the forest the Black
Forest bro really stupid of this guy to
explore an abandoned forest a little of
nowhere not know where this is nope
where when do I need to get a uh I
probably need to get some to climb up
there oh wait no they III III III III
know this is dark out here my sanity is
gonna suffer okay
oh I can't carry but I could throw it I
can really throw it okay hoo oh god it's
so heavy
Oh up nope duck what they'll get the
bass out of it or oh there we go
I'm up and we're here okay so I have a
crowbar here for to apply great force
for which to appeal ah now don't fall
down ah bad time to fall down ah yep
you're feeling it's gonna be a pooper is
gonna be a bummer it's gonna be a bummer
I was pretty sure he's gonna be improved
haha smack myself in the nose why don't
I hey-ohh
a sanity potion whoa no no thank you
oh my felt like this fighter was
crawling up my neck for a second there
oh this custom story is no pill okay
okay what's back here a hidey hole I'm
gonna put this back cuz I know I'm gonna
need this hidey hole I hide from the
monster that's probably gonna run
straight out from my nightmares
this barrel over here and get some nice
protection going on here it's always
important to practice safe amnesia door
key yep
why what's in here oh hello aiexander
good as always to see you use me I need
you up oh I didn't go to get a hot chow
I'm gonna do it anyway hot y'all sorry
if I overloaded the mic there lever
ah don't need to tell me twice
ha ha ha [ __ ] out all I get is wait a
minute I want to see where that other
nope no I don't either I can wait oh oh
boy oh boy oh boy
that was moose man by the way I was I
thought I heard the chase music maybe I
didn't maybe I just associated the chase
music would you explain by I thought I
heard a little bit of it so it was
really a good idea that I didn't go in
there this year
Oh Lord
ah why oh no not again
Oh get open get open get up and get over
no ever got airier Oh dead bird lovely
candles holy oil even lovelier always
good to see the oil oh look at that
oil prove it in a sanity potion didn't
the boat okay good thing they haven't
thrown any puzzles at me
who knows puzzle - the bane of my
existence
ok
this room looks almost pleasant I wonder
when that's going to change
okay hello everybody in yeah anyway our
bone but your bone no no not this luck -
it's in there see something I see a
little Shum Shum I didn't actually pin
this one this one's a much nicer than
the other room
well I guess comparatively - everything
else is still you know monsters in this
castle so I don't think anyone's a
monster key aha
drawing of a desk oh that makes sense
not really but whatever aha
yeah the way books we ever did anyone
any good up skull okay short key tag
displays a chest icon ah I think I know
what's going on here where that blood
stain come from
okay I'll wait a little bit excessive on
my part it's just a door just a door
sorry to scare anyone if I startled you
just a door please tell me it was just a
door
another key copper key sweet entrance
that's a sweet entrance bro like the
triple backflip we did come in there all
right
I really wonder what that door that I
didn't get to in the beginning was you
know the door the ID I never even
touched it
oh man I I'm noticing I'm going slower
through this castle than I ever have and
I think for good reason
cuz I'm I'm a little uh hide behind me
hi me hi me hi me hi hi good I can't go
No ah hi you don't see me I'm so boned
go over there oh why couldn't I get up
here before
go away mousse man oh go away I'm not
doing so well that's better
ha ha ha go away oh hey oh god is it
worse when they throw a monster at you
there's nowhere to hide
you gotta do this stupid thing where you
stare at a corner Oh
little ooh oh go away what are you doing
is in there oh come on
Oh move go please
he's not moving
oh he's not moving is he like a [ __ ]
or something if I go down there is easy
just gonna poof or is he's supposed to
kill me okay let's try something ah
Oh poof poof poof okay yeah that's right
yeah go there that's where I am I gotta
get one out the door ah I missed
ah boop boop you bastard hey you went
outside yay
I'm not about to lose my say oh god I
just took sanity potion I'm not doing
well
Oh what do i do what do i do what do i
do oh my leg
mouse lag latency I don't know cuz it
stared the corner for a bit late the
kennel oh god let's go there Oh leave is
he leaving
always leaving uh-huh oh god oh god
finally oh man how is the worst how is
the worst I'm just gonna stand here in
the light for a little bit not go insane
not waste another sandy push man this
smart isn't draining my sanity like
crazy it's been ridiculous oh man okay
he's gone please be gone hi hey moose
man so much oh all right so I think he
busted out of this room I think that's
how that happened
oh look so whole body y'all I'll close
that up again ten bucks
he said biggie giving me plenty of those
anything in here secret ten bucks
ah well now bar - arya-aa it was so
nonchalantly it isn't little it wasn't
even like it quick says her little dupe
some wrong with your spine there dead
guy no Daniel haven't heard your voice
in a while oh my sanity is like
crippling low I gotta stand here in the
life for just a little bit lemon little
candle just my little candle nothing can
hurt me when I got my little candle here
oh man this has been a good custom story
baton you OOP okay okay
Oh
crawl crawl on my belly hold on my belly
there's a dead body here like so many
other places I've been there are dead
bodies everywhere okay obviously I came
in this room for a reason there's got to
be like a key or something behind a book
what was that nothin nothin nothin
nothin nothin nothin nothin nothin okay
there's got to be a key or something or
some reason for being in here no wrong
oh okay it's been a while since I heard
Daniel voice he's still crazy murdering
psychopath I'll be wrong
oh so ah ha - known repeating alright
South Winky let's get out here oh that's
new that is you excuse me buddy
pardon me when things start to whisper
that's a bad sign very quiet very quiet
it's so quiet
something's gonna happen okay there's a
good hiding place
a door slammed in somewhere else in my
house hey he's gonna chair no okay okay
good a place there's a good attaboy
oh good Adam lit this is good at a place
a mama man can't give me here
that's right back off oh man who a man
that whole quiet session I was killing
it
it was just so unbelievably glad I knew
something was gonna happen I just knew
something was gonna happen
Oh feedback hope you didn't see me you
didn't see me I'm tucked in my corner
behind a bookshelf thank you thank you
for bashing down that door oh boy
jump cut now we just dodged a moose Van
Osten gusty a dead body over there and
we're doing okay
hey about it how is you you don't look
so good kind of blocking the door that's
that's the door to the room I was just
in where I got this key Wow okay however
everything sent me off there's like
noise going off in my house my phone
just give me a text so okay south wing
get the key cellphone key name seemed
seems to imply access to more of the
castle oh good there's anything I want
it's more of this castle who quickload
there's a small area or something
Kim ha I can move I cannot move oh okay
okay
bring it bring it
oh noes the end I'm if I know I hate it
when I do this like the end is like
right there and I end an episode right
before it but man oh man that was great
it was just so short oh that's good
that's a shame I was having fun with
that one oh man
it did say work in progress in the
description in the first episode but
anyway so I'm gonna do the same thing
that I did before and stitch it to the
other one so thank you all so much for
watching I hope you enjoyed this custom
story and I'll try to find more and
music content it's hard to find you know
there aren't that many a music custom
stories that are long like lost the
lights are the things in the night so
I'm hoping to find another one like that
but you know it's are there aren't that
many out there so thank you all so much
for watching and as always see you in
the next part video thing
bye bye